i'm jealous of youtubers who get
cancelled you know they just get like
they just gotta take a break they just
get to like [ __ ] off for four months you
know what i mean like there's some stuff
just getting cancelled you get a sleep
sketch
i'm like [ __ ] off man you canceled him
he gets to take a four month like paid
vacation his videos are still getting
views what are you all about like this
maybe this isn't going to come back come
back in five months
david dobrik got two month vacation
that's all he got
this is [ __ ]
so what's it what is the right amount of
time for like a youtuber council break i
don't know
but the more the more the more when i
saw david dobrik and he came back zero
repercussions his views came as his
video that he came back with got the
same amount of views dislikes likes are
amazing you got amazing likes yeah you
know i'm like this one got a [ __ ]
month vacation this is [ __ ] and he
got he got free articles about him he
can get verified now on twitter
he wasn't already but i was like what
the [ __ ] he had a double there was like
no no there was like no repercussions
and i'm like wow what what what point is
it like damn cancer doesn't look too
right too bad right now i mean
if if logan paul can literally come back
from showing a dead body i feel like
anyone can come back you know it's
it's kind of the truth
oh
that was a joke joey said a joke is a
joke please don't cancel jerry
but i was just thinking about it because
you're saying that like oh um my mom
made many jumps and logic there um
because you were saying oh yeah well
you've got [ __ ] to do but when you you
know when you were as youtubers you
always have to do does there's no
vacations you can't just take a month
off
people take a month off for a mental
health break which is like i say with
inverted commerce because it's kind of
become a cliche now even though it's
very important and beautiful do you
[ __ ] need it but you know it's sad
because if you get cancelled you almost
get a better vacation because there's
people still talking about you while
you're gone and people like searching
about you and making videos about you
like i know that sounds awful and you
know it's not great but like you are
still getting way more traffic yeah than
you would be just taking a break right
so if you do something kind of
semi-semi-bad you know just something
that's like
do something light you know just just do
something like oh just i don't know just
fart on a dog or something i don't know
just something that's like not too
bad
what's something that you can you'll get
backlash for but isn't really that bad
that you can just come back from in a
month you know what i mean and then
you'll get your cat vodka
yeah i literally did that [ __ ] perfectly
fine
starting to think i should get a pet
that's a joke
that's a joke that's a check this is a
trash taste getting cancelled speed run
yeah can we get it i just thought about
it and i was like hold on a second all
these people just get like
basically paid vacation this is [ __ ]
i mean i think it's like different
severities yeah the people get like
quite severe yeah it's quite bad but
i've noticing more and more a lot of
them just
if they haven't really done anything
criminal mm-hmm they just kind of like
bounce back super easily i mean there
are some people who did choose
davidson was kind of criminal to be fair
let's be honest yeah it was it was kind
of criminal i mean it
endangered someone's life
came back all right like it just amazes
me it's like it's like a jesus christ
like a cult yeah but then there's like
examples like edp 455.
he's he's definitely not coming back
i mean he's trying to realize
that edp was a youtuber who uh got
caught trying to meet up with 14 year
olds yeah and uh didn't he like try to
start his own website or something yeah
he did he actually yeah he did because
he he got his youtube band and then he
was like finna go to facebook you know
it's better than his facebook golfbidder
yeah facebook and so he's like
i'm gonna start my own website
he's trying really hard man but yeah the
the main point of this whole me going on
this tangent was that uh yeah i feel
like yeah as youtubers you don't really
get a break i know we're complaining oh
boohoo us uh who cares i mean we have
easy jobs so whatever but i mean it's
you know we don't really get like set
vacations which sucks um and i kind of
miss you know one thing i really do miss
doing is just being able to two weeks
off just play video games
just catch up with [ __ ] like i don't
even want to go places anymore like
because i travel anyway on like weekends
i find three days here and there that's
fun but it feels like you're still doing
something
but i just want that that i miss that
feeling of like i'm gonna take two weeks
off catch up to all the movies catch up
to all the manga just kidding play all
video games you know maybe might start
persona probably won't just buy it just
look at it so many games so many games
in my backlog that i just want to play
like the new mass effect remaster got
released and i'm just like i want to
play that but i'm going to i haven't
even played persona 5 royal yeah and
[ __ ] it [ __ ] knows where i'm gonna get
the time to do that
yeah i now have two wish lists i have
the wishlist where i will actually use
the thing and the wishlist where this is
just a wish list where it would be nice
but i won't use that yeah it's the
cancelled wishes yeah because like you
said you had a day
the other day where you just woke up and
you did nothing and it was i mean yeah i
kind of just woke up one day and i was
like well i don't really have any like
videos to work on i don't really have
any like other side projects to work on
so i'm just like you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna do a power move yeah not do
anything like not do anything without i
didn't even check my phone that day i
was like not phone turning off i'm just
gonna do [ __ ] around the house and just
hang out and i was like yeah damn is
this what like a weekend feels for every
other person
i'm literally experiencing a weekend for
the first time in my life i was like oh
my god this is f i should do this more
often yeah [ __ ] like i think for us
especially the last few months have just
been super [ __ ] busy with us building
this set and having to like film a bunch
of episodes to get ahead i remember we
had like what like this two-week period
where it was like we finished building
the set then we filmed the trash taste
episode every day for like yeah it was
like we had a recording session with
either trash taste or like a netflix
shoot or some kind of some kind of other
live stream every day for like two weeks
without any breaks on weekends or
anything that was brutal that was like i
was i was like close to burn out there
yeah i do film my schedule up on black
yeah
like
i'm i'm jealous of you right i'm jealous
of you the most because you you view
streaming as a down time i'm just like i
i wish [ __ ] you think i wish my down
time could be work
i wish i could get paid i wish i could
be paid for my downs